Я їх порівнюю зі здими дітьми, яким дали іграшку,
вони сидять і колупають: хочуть подивитися, що там усередині.
Потім - раз! - зламали. От вони зараз так сидять і колупають країну.
Ви заявляли, що з президентом не граєте в ромашку, тобто в любить-не любить.
У вільній країні, коли люди вільно висловлюють свою думку,
це не значить, що в обмін їм треба передавати привіти через якихось третіх осіб
про те, що з Філатовим розмова тільки одна:
або він пише заяву про звільнення, або ми його посадимо.
Що саме ви не можете поділити з олігархом Ігорем Коломойським?
Якщо ти повинен щиро, чесно і правильно представляти територіальну громаду,
ти повинен починати з ними конфліктувати.
Навіщо ви знову хочете балотуватися на посаду мера Дніпра?
Я хочу закінчити розпочате.
Пане Філатов, Ви заявляли, що президент Зеленський в Україні розбудовує КПРС.
Де Ви побачили сліди КПРС? Можете сказати?
Та у всьому. Це ніби "секрет Полішинеля".
Дивіться, КПРС мався на увазі не з точки зору комуністичної ідеології,
а з точки зору побудови партії. Знаєте, як казав класик,
що б не будували, зрештою виходить КПРС. Я кажу про монопартію, яка намагається
взяти під контроль усі можливі і неможливі вертикалі влади.
Ось, наприклад, остання заява, яку зробив  Володимир Олександрович про те,
що ті мери, які проти вертикалі влади, що  вони і проти президента
і мало не проти України. Але місцеве самоврядування -
це не вертикаль влади. Згадаймо сумний приклад Партії регіонів.
Вони теж хотіли отримати повний політичний диктат по всій країні,
але навіть в місцевому самоврядуванні не вийшло.
У нас дуже складна, різна країна, тому це явно нездійсненна мета.
Країна стала зовсім іншою. Тобто неможливо зламати її через коліно. Не-мож-ли-во.
Ви порівнюєте правлячу партію з тим, що було в Україні в часи Януковича?
Я порівнюю методи. Тобто методи дуже схожі.
Називаймо речі своїми іменами. В принципі, Петро Олексійович у 2015-тому році
приніс зокрема мені багато неприємних моментів. Це правда.
Але при цьому, коли я бачу зараз, що йому штампують кримінальні справи просто пачками,
те, що відбувається з ним зараз, це все одно зрозуміло, що це політичні репресії.
Я не захищаю його. Я кажу про інституційні речі.
От оприлюднені оці плівки. Хтось комусь щось сказав.
Байден? Не Байден? Я не слухаю навіть ці плівки. Мені є чим займатися.
А уявіть собі, якщо з'ясується, що ці плівки, їхній витік був з Офісу Президента.
Тобто я не вірю, що це Путін їх публікує.
Можливо, таким чином вони розважаються. Але треба розуміти, що такі записи -
не знаю, порізана, непорізана, справжня, несправжня, -
у них термін 25 років для непублікації.
А якщо це з'ясується в майбутньому? Це хіба не ящик Пандори?
Я їх порівнюю зі злими дітьми, яким дали іграшку,
а вони сидять, колупають, хочуть подивитися, що ж там усередині. Потім раз - зламали.
Ось вони так зараз сидять і колупають країну.
Тому вони можуть мене любити або не любити, але я вважаю, що
вони - злі діти, але країна - не іграшка. Країна - не іграшка.
Її не треба сидіти й розбирати, збирати і розбирати. Тому що вона може зламатися.
Чи можете Ви підтвердити, що те, що відбувається наразі така собі
конфронтація між центральною і місцевою владою, означає
відкат реформи децентралізації чи то наступ на місцеве самоврядування?
Це очевидні речі. Звичайно. Йде наступ на права місцевого самоврядування.
Коли ми говоримо про децентралізацію, насправді децентралізація
була таким собі симулятором. Зараз Петро Олексійович, Володимир Гройсман
намагаються говорити, що вони були родоначальниками децентралізації.
Так, вони попустили віжки і дали більше фінансового ресурсу територіальним громадам,
але фактично нам особливо і не передавали повноваження.
Тобто в нас немає взагалі ніякого інструментарію,
яким ми можемо впливати на якісь процеси. У мене було відчуття "дежавю".
Щороку перед ухваленням держбюджету збиралися всі мери, їхали до прем'єр-міністра,
їхали до президента, лаялися, щороку нам намагалися обрізати бюджет.
Щороку були постійні дискусії з депутатським корпусом.
Але те, що відбувається зараз, це взагалі просто тотальне згортання і тотальне нерозуміння.
Якщо тоді був симулякр і ніби така гра в піддавки, але хоча б за це спасибі.
То зараз взагалі декларується одне, говориться інше, робиться третє,
а думається, мабуть, геть  інше.
У випадку бюджету Дніпра як це виглядає?
Мінус 3 млрд у цьому році. Вони так накерували, що в Дніпрі фактично 2,5 млрд
і ще плюс 500 млн ми отримали мінус через епідемію коронавірусу.
Тобто Вас викликали перед прийняттям бюджету?
Ні.
Слухали і нічого не зробили, чи як?
Зі мною взагалі не розмовляють. Напевно, тому, що у мене є своя позиція.
Це позиція не просто як політика, а позиція як громадянина.
Логіка дуже проста. Є Європейська хартія місцевого самоврядування.
Візьміть її, імплементуйте і взагалі більше нічого не придумуйте.
І нехай буде, як в Польщі, або як в Німеччині, або іншій країні ЄС.
Повертаючись до Ваших стосунків із президентом Зеленським:
Ви заявили, що з президентом Зеленським Ви не граєте в ромашку,
тобто любить-не любить. Але питання про те,
любить Вас Зеленський чи ні, залишається відкритим.
Треба йому поставити це запитання. Я не граю в ромашку.
А дивіться, мене не треба любити або не любити.
Я – обраний більшістю територіальної громади, сподіваюся, успішний мер.
Зрозуміло, в будь-якому випадку завжди є незадоволені.
Це нормально. Крім того, ми живемо у вільній країні.
У вільній країні, коли люди висловлюють вільно свою думку, це не значить,
що у відповідь їм потрібно надсилати поліцію або спрецпризначенців із автоматами,
наприклад, на Міськводоканал. І все.
Або передавати привіти через якихось третіх осіб про те, що з Філатовим розмова тільки одна:
або він пише заяву на звільнення, або ми його посадимо в тюрму. Ну, нехай посадять!
Напередодні місцевих виборів Ви разом із мерами інших міст створили партію "Пропозиція"
і одразу пішли на конфронтацію з командою Президента.
Тож яка Ваша пропозиція центральній владі?
Я б не перекладав "Пропозиція", як "пропозиція".
"Пропозиція" - це фактично ми вважаємо, що вводимо таким чином в політологічний,
скажімо так, обіг нове слово. Ну, можна розуміти і як "пропозиція".
Ми говоримо про те, що ми є людьми, які не є ворогами для центральної влади.
Ми не є в класичному сенсі слова опозицією.
Ми для центральної влади, яка повинна схаменутися рано чи пізно,
є фактично рятувальним колом. Не ми як персоналії:
Філатов, Іванов, Петров, Сидоров, а ми як місцеве самоврядування.
Вони повинні віддати вниз на місця повноваження
людям у вигляді місцевого самоврядування.
Більш того, я скажу, я прихильник того, щоб і свої повноваження передавати вниз.
Якщо Ви думаєте, що мені подобається, коли до мене приходять на прийом 80 осіб
і просять поставити дитячий майданчик або заасфальтувати двір… Це не нормально!
Мер повинен займатися мостами, метро, аеропортом - інфраструктурними проєктами,
охороною здоров'я. У мене повинна бути можливість,
у місцевого самоврядування, зокрема, спускати фінанси вниз,
у будинкові комітети, у мікрорайонні комітети.
Але нам же цього не дають!
Через те, що йде наступ на права місцевого самоврядування,
нам довелося об'єднатися в політичну силу,
оскільки в один момент ми зрозуміли, що нам не вдасться
відсидітися кожен у себе за парканом.
У тому числі - і я повторюю це скрізь, - ми відкриті для всіх інших мерів.
Наші руки лежать на столі.
Якщо хтось думає що він переобереться від своєї карликової партії,
а потім ми будемо об'єднуватися, вони просто не розуміють,
що якщо політикою не починати займатися зараз, то політика займеться нами.
Вона вже нами займається.
Чи можете Ви підтвердити чи спростувати, що бізнесмен Геннадій Корбан
може очолити передвиборчий штаб партії "Пропозиція"?
Я не можу це ні підтвердити, ні спростувати.
Я з Геннадієм Корбаном більше 20 років, ми не приховуємо наших стосунків.
У нас в партії приймаються колективні рішення.
Якщо колеги ухвалять таке рішення або схвалять, чому ні?
Послухайте, Геннадій Корбан, будучи головою політради Партії "Укроп",
вивів її на виборах 2015-го року на 7% по країні.
Він - висококваліфікована людина, він зовсім не токсичний,
як би на нього не вішали якихось собак.
Ви заявляли, що в Україні ситуація в регіонах напередодні місцевих виборів доволі загрозлива.
І Ви повідомили про це західним дипломатам. Про що саме?
Я не буду персонально говорити. Це не зовсім правильно,
тому що розмови носили такий конфіденційний характер.
Є подробиці, які краще в публічному інтерв'ю взагалі не згадувати
Скажімо так. Послів G7.
Я сказав, що відбувається наступ на права місцевого самоврядування,
використання адмінресурсу, порушення кримінальних справ необґрунтованих.
Простий приклад наведу. Знаєте, скільки кримінальних справ проти Дніпровської мерії?
286!
А до суду скільки дійшло? 30!
А вироків? Один.
Зараз вони кілька десятків справ потягли в ГПУ. І так відбувається не тільки в Дніпрі.
Наприклад, у Анатолія Бондаренка в Черкасах повністю вивернули все.
У нього взагалі аудит.
У Чернівцях меру придумують постійно протоколи про корупцію з боку НАЗК.
Зараз у нього суд по відстороненню. І так відбувається скрізь.
Головне те, що я знаходжу з західними дипломатами спільну мову. Вони теж це бачать.
Чи дійсно партію будуть фінансувати не олігархи, а небайдужі громадяни?
Це те що обіцяють зазвичай перед виборами, але не завжди виконують. Як це буде у Вас?
Чесно скажу, у нас зараз немає спонсорів. Ми ні з ким не ведемо переговори,
тому що, об'єктивно кажучи, ми зараз говоримо про місцеві вибори.
І в будь-якому разі на місцевих виборах кожен мер повинен був задіяти свій ресурс.
Навіщо нам знаходити спонсорів, щоб вони нам потім казали: візьміть цих кандидатів і оцих.
У нас кожен в партії відповідає за свій регіон
і у нього є повне право ухвалювати управлінські рішення з цього регіону самостійно -
без настійливих рекомендацій або колег, або когось ззовні. Поки нас це влаштовує.
Що саме Ви не можете поділити з олігархом Ігорем Коломойським?
Я з ним взагалі нічого не хочу ділити. Я хочу, щоб він про мене забув.
Я про це говорю постійно і знову-таки
не хочу переходити в наші з ним суб'єктивні особисті стосунки. Хороший він, поганий.
Я говорю про те, що в місті Дніпро все, до чого б не доторкнувся, перетворив у тлін і прах.
Аеропорт, футбольний клуб, недобудована баскетбольна арена,
Будинок офіцерів, колишній картінг- центр.
Ця вся їх компашка. Все, до чого вони торкнулися в місті, лежить у руїнах.
У тому числі одним з моїх з ним конфліктів було те, що коли клуб "Дніпро"
з десятками років історії футбольної беруть і закривають,
приходять не до нього, а до мера. І кажуть: як так?
Коли з аеропорту Дніпра неможливо полетіти, а квитки до Києва коштують дорожче,
ніж квиток Київ-Нью-Йорк,
приходять до мера і кажуть: Борисе Альбертовичу, це ж ваші друзі,
партнери, це ваші давні стосунки, якось вам усім гуртом мало б бути соромно.
І потім ти розумієш: якщо ти повинен  щиро, чесно і правильно представляти територіальну громаду,
ти повинен починати з ними конфліктувати.
А вони у відповідь про тебе показують страшні фільми на підконтрольних телеканалах
або роблять фейки.
Навіщо Ви знов вирішили балотуватися на посаду мера Дніпра?
Дуже просто. Я завжди кажу і повторю ще раз: я хочу закінчити розпочате.
Що саме?
Я зробив дуже багато. Я зробив за 5 років більше, ніж усі попередники за 25 -30 років.
Дуже багато зроблено, не хочу перераховувати.
Наприклад, у нас в місті не працювали ліфти, деякі не працювали по 25 років.
У ліфтових шахтах люди зберігали дивани та консервацію.
Ми повністю змінили транспортну систему, запустили кілька нових тролейбусних маршрутів,
причому, як я кажу, при поганому Петі. При хорошому Вові поки жодного.
Зараз Придніпровський електробус запустимо. Дахи, ремонти…
І тільки зараз ми цей іржавий паровоз, цю машину розігнали, і вона зараз поїхала.
Ті, не будемо обговорювати кандидатів, які сподіваються прорватися
і якось обігнати Філатова на повороті…
Маєте на увазі Максима Бужанського від партії "Слуга народу"?
Він може вести будь-яку активну діяльність, але у них ще не визначилися.
У них три кандидати або чотири. Вони між собою сваряться, створюють штаби.
Я просто хочу сказати, що будь-яка людина, яка думає,
що це крісло, в яке вона сяде, буде легко. Ні, буде нелегко.
А, в принципі, цей паровоз запущений, він поїхав.
Я хочу завершити розпочате і спокійно,
через 5 років, піти на пенсію, щоб остаточно не з'їхати з глузду. Все.
Ви сказали, що центральна влада хоче, щоб Ви пішли у відставку.
Але Ви самі, погодилися піти у відставку? Ви думали?
Проблема в тому, що, на жаль, коли ти йдеш в політику,
у тебе рубль вхід і навіть не два рубля  вихід, а 10-ть.
І ти починаєш відповідати не тільки за недовиконані обіцянки
або виникає бажання закінчити розпочате, але ти ще відповідаєш за команду.
Плюс, ти розумієш, що вся ця зграя, яка тобі чіпляється за ноги, вона, якщо, припустімо,
ти грюкнеш дверима і підеш, вона не залишить тебе в спокої і буде далі переслідувати.
Тому я не знаю, напевно, якісь дуже особисті моменти. Я навіть не хочу замислюватися.